bang-bang what's up lunch money time
while Wall Street is trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right coming to you everyday
noon ish is because we don't got our
[ __ ] together sometimes before noon
afternoon right at noon or 5:00 p.m. the
beautiful and intelligent plain Amer
Nova is here to keep us on track what's
up well life goin for me yes okay but
four five point two four five million
Americans not so great what happened
more than five million Americans filed
first time claims for unemployment this
week so 5.2 million Americans it was
reported this morning unemployment
claims in the last week add that to the
16 million unemployment claims the three
weeks before that puts us at almost 22
million unemployment claims in a month
22 million if you add that 22 million to
the 5.8 million Americans that were
already unemployed at the end of
February that means that almost twenty
eight million Americans are now
unemployed that's the official number
that's been reported
we know it's higher than that gig
economy workers freelancers
self-employed people who are trying to
file can't get through all that kind of
stuff but 28 million Americans right now
are unemployed no that's 22 in the last
week but here's the worst part 28
million Americans out of 165 million
that are considered in the labor force
means that we were at 16% unemployment
right now so is that this has nearly
wiped out all the job gains since the
Great Recession yeah probably
I mean look 16 percent unemployment is
horrendous right and to put it in
historical context during the Great
Depression 1929 before the Great
Depression started unemployment was at
3.1 percent right so a historic low
similar to what we just had in February
with 3.5% it's a very similar situation
it took from 1929 to 1930
to go from 3.5 it's about 8.5% and then
in 1931 two years later it took we
eventually got to over 15% like 15.8% or
something and then and only then did we
go up over 20% in year three in 1932
1933 1934 and so what's scary about this
is we went from three point five percent
which is very low to we're now at
sixteen percent in a month I mean six
weeks right four to six weeks we're
already there and so similar to how like
the virus everyone's worried about how
fast it can spread right what I'm
worried about is the rate at which this
is happening it took two years to go
from three you know percent and change
to 15% during the Great Depression we've
done it in four to six weeks yeah so at
this rate we'll see twenty percent
unemployment by the end of q2 right and
I mean literally by the end of June
about twenty percent of employment
United States yeah they expect that
April jobless rate to fifteen to twenty
percent
it's crazy that is crazy so okay so now
the government is talking about a
possible May timeline for reopening the
economy in some way well so here's the
sad part right this is where you have to
remember when I say twenty eight million
Americans are out of work
every single one of those numbers is a
human right that had a job or should
have a job and doesn't thread twenty
eight million of them is a massive
number right sixteen percent of the
workforce what I'm worried about is when
they turn the economy back on first of
all if you're a restaurant let's say you
employed a hundred people when they now
say okay turn back on you're not gonna
have 100 percent of your customers come
back on day one so you may hire back 50
60 70 maybe even 80 percent of the
people that you had right and so you're
still not gonna hire back 100 percent of
them right out of the gate you may do it
over time but not initially so there
will be some people who can't go back to
their jobs and that will keep
unemployment at a higher level we won't
go back to 3.5% on top of that though
how many small businesses aren't coming
back 25 30 50 percent I don't
the numbers but it's gonna be a
double-digit percentage of companies
that got shut down by the government and
they're not gonna come back and all of
the jobs are gonna be lost to the job
opportunities so what ends up happening
here is this unemployment numbers gonna
stay high for a while but the solution
to the unemployment get Americans back
to work by opening the economy or that's
the simple answer what's the complex
answer or the next next topic some House
Democrats won't introduce a plan to pay
Americans $2,000 a month until the
economy recovers from koban 19th what is
recovers me okay so let's set the stage
real quick so far the government has
acknowledged there's really high
unemployment there are people suffering
we need to help that's step one that's
great that they've acknowledged that
step two then is how do we help yeah so
far what they've decided to do is launch
stimulus packages right those stimulus
packages have two core components for
individuals the first is they've beefed
up uninsured unemployment insurance so
if you used to apply it's from
unemployment insurance you now can get
what you would have gotten plus I think
it's about two six hundred or more a
week they're trying to get people more
money into their hands right that's the
first step the second step is they also
offered up to twelve hundred dollars for
some number of Americans as a one-time
payment right we talked about before
kind of a bribe to keep the social
unrest at bay and so that $1,200 payment
is now starting to hit but as we've
previously discussed it doesn't help
people for a long period of time may
help me for a month right and so what
this proposal is is two lawmakers have
come forward and they call it the
emergency money to the people Act let's
bail out the people so let's describe
what it is first and then we'll talk
about whether we think it's good enough
oh so US citizens who are over the age
of 16 and make less than $130,000 a year
would receive cash payments from the
federal government for at least six
months and until unemployment falls to
pre-pandemic lows so the whole question
is what if that never happens what if it
takes hold on the cash payments too
right so they would pay you $2,000 oh ma
actually quite a bit of money $24,000 a
year which is basically under the
poverty line though so basically they
would pay you $2,000 a month every month
until the we reached the unemployment
levels of pre koban which means that
we'd have to drop back nothing - three
point five percent unemployment
newsflash yellow flag yellow flag
penalty penalty this is socialism here's
why universal basic income is exactly
what this is talking about they are
proposing user ear bristle universal
basic income they can call an emergency
money for the people it sounds great
power to the people all this stuff flag
its socialism here's why if you're going
to give people two thousand dollars a
month and you do it every single month
there's two problems with why you'll
never stop the first is if you say that
we have to go back to pre-pandemic
levels of unemployment that means that
we have to get back to three point five
percent which was a historic low it will
take ten years or more to get there
right that is the low at the height of
an economic boom so you have to go
through a whole nother cycle to get
there they'll be giving people $2,000 a
month forever the second and the more
important thing is this is political
suicide for a politician there is not a
politician in the world who is going to
stand up and say we've given you $2,000
a month every month for the last three
years and now we're taking it away no
way it's not gonna happen so what ends
up happening is we now have to make a
decision are we gonna go to universal
basic income or are we not right in some
weird way these people are making Andrew
yang seem conservative right cuz he only
want to get people a thousand dollars of
course so they're gonna give me two
thousand dollars here's a great fact
Erik Voorhees from shape-shift pointed
this out if they were to do what they're
proposing in this emergency money to the
people Act it would be four hundred
billion dollars a month in cost to the
government which is more money than the
government spends everything combined
right now a month so they would
basically be at least doubling their
expenses on a monthly basis
and they would based on the current
Fed's balance sheet it would be 5% or
more increase every single month with no
end in sight and so what you do is
you've got to make a decision do we stay
to the capitalistic ideals that we hold
or do we move into this socialistic
world where there's a social safety net
there's people smarter than me they're
gonna make this decision guess what our
opinions actually don't really matter
there's elected officials they're gonna
make the decision the idea right now of
giving people money when they're
absolutely begging for help
seems like it's gonna be pretty popular
with the people but it just puts us on a
slippery slope right but it's important
to note that this is just the bill
proposed by these two Democrats there's
gonna be I think lots of different types
of things proposed and this time it's
just you have to pay attention to what's
going on but this is not set in stone by
any means socialism socialism alert
penalty penalty it's a yellow flag
penalty I'm just sayin all right let's
move on we got for us
blue jeans pants on No so you know how
you don't even wear jeans anymore I know
I wear sweatpants shorts whatever let's
go shorts until they tell them about our
argument the other day she got she got
mad at me because I got mad at her for
washing my sweat pants shorts she said
that's been 2 weeks I said so what's
wrong with going to three weeks without
washing them who cares let's go blue
jeans blue jeans so Verizon is swooping
in and once to buy tsums one of zooms
biggest competitors called blue jeans
it's a work from home you know remote
virtual videoconferencing company so so
yeah with all these people working
remotely I think Verizon sees an
opportunity
agreed d ting is a good purchase or bad
purchase I mean so they're gonna pay
less than 500 million
I don't 500 millions not so cheap in the
age we're about trillions of stimulus
trillions and billion tire sector of
videoconferencing has exploded people
see the value stock
are going up zoom has seen it absolutely
take off what is interesting though is
that zoom slack and Microsoft teams are
kind of the leaders in the categories
the what is this thing called blue jeans
it's popular but it's not nearly as
popular as the other ones and so I think
that recently sure interrupt me like
that which is a rare thing to say in the
world of tech oh my god we should have a
standing ovation somebody figured out
that the point of business is to be
profitable
I roll all right so here's the deal I
think that it's smart we're gonna see a
bunch of consolidation it's very
interesting that they're doing it right
now when I'm assuming that blue jeans
has taken off in growth and revenue and
if that's the case I wonder if actually
on a multiple basis they overpay and
then once the economy comes back do
people stop using it as much as it
becomes less popular like it wouldn't
surprise me to see a corporation make a
panic move into buying something and
then regret it six months later yeah but
also it's a good time to buy something
with blue jeans because zoom right now
is being criticized for its security and
privacy practices and I believe the
Department of Education in New York
actually banned schools from using zoom
so newsflash
nobody cares why makes headlines yeah
there's like they lose a customer here
they're like nobody cares
Department of Education if I'm one
customer nobody cares
they went from ten million daily active
Zoar monthly actives to two hundred
literally they explode 20x growth nobody
cares
at for every headline that you see it if
you're like all the security whatever
nobody cares it's like tick tock right
tick tock by China
nobody cares they got 90 million people
using it or whatever okay moving on to
Facebook Facebook Oh what are they doing
they're starting to warn people who like
a reactive fake Korean coronavirus news
this is a slippery slope I used to work
at Facebook I'm a huge fan I really
really believe in the team they're there
I genuinely believe they're great people
and they try to do their best but they
are faced with highly complex decisions
this is one of them on one hand you want
to make decisions too
I try to prevent the spread of fake news
you want to try to you know incentivize
people not to post that stuff etc on the
other hand you enter into this weird
debate of what's fake news of what's not
fake news and I'll give you a perfect
example so one of you two examples
the first is Zero Hedge is a popular
Twitter account and Zero Hedge about six
weeks ago posted a article claiming that
the corona virus could have potentially
started in the biology lab at the
University of Wuhan and that all they
basically claimed was that there's a
study of coronaviruses going on there
and it got out from the lab and
basically spread around the world they
were kicked off Twitter and pretty much
everyone laughed at them and said no way
you know how is that true you guys are
conspiracy theorists all the stuff we
now have US intelligence officers that
are saying they are looking at this as a
credible potential story and they're
trying to figure out how much validity
it has and it's being reported by the
mainstream press now and so what ends up
happening is six six weeks ago you had
corona virus in the Wuhan lab was
thought of as fake news conspiracy
theory essentially you guys here that
we're gonna cut that part of the audio
now I'm just gonna run that as a loop in
our life over those run over and over
again it's on real business insider so
the other piece of it though is now it's
not considered fake news now it's a
plausible thing right there senators
talking about etc so my point is do we
want Facebook being the arbiter of
what's real and what's not
probably not Facebook doesn't want to do
that either so what they usually do in
these situations they go and they build
these committees where it's like fact
checkers and all its kind of stuff and
they use those committees to determine
the problem is another situation would
have been when the CDC and the w-h-o
said that masks don't work they're liars
so how so do you now say Polina and pop
are saying masks are necessary go buy a
mask put
ask on vs. the CDC in the w-h-o Facebook
in that committee are more likely to
side with CDC and whu-oh and say you
guys are spreading fake news we get
punished but actually in reality or
right now so well the face mask thing it
was an evolution right first they were
saying one thing then they got more
facts learned about the situation in
nature listen I had no facts they think
that we're stupid
the masked work everyone knew that
literally people in Jamie we're like put
a mask on the CDC when it came out is
better get new facts what they were
trying to do was they were trying to
prevent people who want to buy up the
mast so there were some for health care
workers so they knowingly lied the guy
yeah it's they because there's a
shortage globally so maybe what they
said is you don't need a mask it doesn't
work because they don't want you go by
the mess they're trying to drive down
the man google google it because i read
the internet and so the whole point is
the idea of fake news all comes down to
how do you determine what's fake and
what's not and the second you get into
this world of somebody's gonna decide
what's fake and what's not
i think it's a really slippery slope and
rather than try to say what's fake and
what's not
i think that they should literally let
all of the information get published and
then allow people to determine that yes
but you don't understand that if you're
in a certain facebook bubble and you're
following all these people in a small
town whatever and they're posting fake
news you're like oh like a New York
Times piece fake news it could lead to
mass in the New York Times posting ways
they've retracted stories how there's a
bunch of fake news right by the way and
it's on both sides liberal and
conservative papers post things that are
inaccurate misleading etc and so what
are you gonna do are you gonna ban the
New York Times from Facebook well I
think right now they're just people
journalists need to have a very very you
have a big responsibility to society and
not publishing things that are biased or
speculative or politicized and I think
what you're trying to say is that trying
to say so again is that a lot of the
information is politicized so it's very
hard to determine fake news
politicise news no I'm gonna take a step
further here you guys want some real
fire for today there is no such thing as
unbiased news it's written by a human
they're all biased
rather than say I'm unbiased I'm holier
than thou let me just sit here and write
unbiased news instead if they should say
here are my bias here is my opinion here
is my understanding of the facts and
here's my conclusion and then allow the
reader to understand what this person is
saying seek out contradicting opinions
and then make your own decision how many
people would actually do that it doesn't
matter how many people will do it it's
the fact that that's what they should do
and whether people do it or not right on
the receiving end that's up to the
people okay I have all right we got one
minute ten seconds can we get through
tick-tock so tick-tock now let's parents
set restrictions on their kids accounts
including restricted content mode
setting screen time limits and the
ability to disable direct messaging
thoughts I think it's actually a good
thing yeah and you know why he thinks
it's a good thing because yesterday we
were on tick-tock and we were going
through and you were like oh my god what
if like daughter was posting videos now
player showed me a video of a mom and
her daughter the Dodgers like six years
old the daughters twerking like she's a
stripper on a pole in her pajamas and
I'm like listen why are these people do
and letting their kids do this crazy
[ __ ] on the internet this is not true
am I wrong yes what am I wrong her
parents decided that was okay and that's
how they were gonna raise their child
again that's fine but what if I don't
want my kid to see okay now I got tools
to do it I don't even have a key can you
imagine if I had a kid that'd be [ __ ]
wild
hopefully it would look like her all
right what else we got ten seconds any
messages for the people be kind to your
friends and to strangers into strangers
now where are the strangers like all of
them well people who are your friends
and people who you want to become their
funds
that's very prophetic of you to uh to
say something like that all right guys
remember lunch money bringing you the
truth
well while she's trying to get the rest
rest of us are trying to get our lunch
money right hopefully you guys are
enjoying this leave us a comment playing
it reads them all tells me the funny
I go through and try to respond to as
many of you as I can we appreciate you
guys watching hopefully you're learning
go share the URL and extra points if you
leave comments making fun a planet we'll
see you guys tomorrow
why would he say that